bene allora io sono lidia schillaci sono
una cantautrice non sono abituata ai
talk più che altro a cantare però oggi
mi sono preparato un po di appunti così
almeno non dimentico niente
sono felice di stare qui e di parlare
del tema della di queste dx unito
internet of people e vi dico perché
diciamo che è un tema su cui mi sono
cimentata con il mio lavoro
meglio così e perché credo profondamente
nella definizione di internet delle
persone e per le persone per me usare
internet usare la connessione e mi
permette di stare più vicina alle
persone e di potenziare appunto le
proprie abilità le proprie passioni
quello che sappiamo fare meglio insomma
anche se oggi dobbiamo dire che siamo un
po tutti automatizzati sentivo prima
appunto il professore io la prima
appunto non non se vi capita di
stare pressato dove cercare una via dove
dover usare il navigatore satellitare io
non ce la faccio per esempio senza il
navigatore non riesco mai a trovare la
via è poi molto spesso mi è anche
capitato che ne so la voce della
migliore di agire a destra agirà a
sinistra una volta il navigatore mi ha
detto gira a destra però a destra il
navigatore non sapevo che c'era il
dirupo meno male che non ho seguito il
consiglio perché sono stati stata non
sarei stata qui a raccontarvi la mia
storia e facciamo fatica a certe volte
che ne so memorizzare non so i numeri di
telefono io appunto facevo fatica di
memorizzare il discorso però magari ce
la farò spero però ecco mi sono fatta un
po di domande e mi sono chiesta nella
mia esperienza quanto ci può servire
internet nella vita quanto ci può
aiutare quanto ci può rendere vicino
alle persone quanto può essere utile a
noi proprio come persone e soprattutto
una domanda me la son o me la sono posta
proprio ben chiara per il mestiere che
faccio
possiamo tramite internet trasmettere
emozioni reali
beh
questa cosa questa cosa è una cosa che
mi ha colpito fin da subito e vi
racconto una storia che è la mia storia
io ho un po di tempo fa stavo scrivendo
dei pezzi in studio e nello stesso
momento
in quello stesso momento dall'altra
parte dell'oceano a san francisco un
gruppo di creativi stava creando e
realizzando un'applicazione che
permetteva tutti noi dal proprio
smartphone di potersi connettere in
diretta in live streaming e poter vedere
cosa succedeva dall'altra parte del
mondo
in quello stesso istante questa
applicazione è arrivata in italia molto
presto
e quando l'ho avuta tra le mani sul mio
telefono ho pensato questa una cosa
geniale è fantastico perché ho subito
collegato e mi è venuto subito la mente
che il mio telefonino poteva diventare
per me che facevo musica il mio
palcoscenico digitale il mio
palcoscenico libero da qualsiasi paletto
potevo fare quello che volevo potevo
esprimermi in piena creatività con la
mia musica
allora ho fatto una cosa ci ho pensato
bene e ho detto sai che faccio
creo crei online voglio creare un lay
voglio dare un nome a questo live ho
creato un piccolo format è in realtà
l'ho chiamato libia live molto semplice
ma ci ho pensato parecchio però insomma
l'idea live consisteva in questo io
stavo a casa e facevo delle live session
delle live session davanti al mio
telefonino prendo questa diretta
streaming
improvvisamente si apriva una diretta
con tantissime persone che mi servivano
da da ogni parte del mondo dall'america
del messico dall'europa
da ovunque io cantavo ho cantato davanti
al mio telefono prima da solo poi detto
no naso la musicista vabbè facciamo
piano e voce chitarra e voce poi
addirittura organizzato delle cene a
casa mi ha invitato tutti i musicisti a
casa mia ho fatto delle jam session
pazzesche c'era da gente dell'altra
parte che scriveva continua continua a
mandare messaggi che si divertiva e in
quel momento stavo condividendo
un'emozione tramite un telefono mi
ricordo ancora oggi non è passato molto
tempo realtà che mi sono presentata con
una prima canzone una canzone che ho
scritto io perché volevo presentarmi
proprio come vorrei fare oggi con voi
questa canzone che ho scritto parla
parla della mia terra parla delle mie
origini sono siciliana e questa canzone
l'ho scritta proprio in siciliano e ve
la voglio dedicare
davanti
titolare
mister
basta
e lì suo
sora
acustici
ma
mostre
così tu
sento tournée
arrivi
sa fare
se ci si
un box
presso
io
agi
questo somma
nasco
si può più stare a tutti
no
ciao
oddio c'è per dire
ho apprezzati addio
questo giorno
chissà
sì
ma
io
grazie mille bene diciamo che in libia
live non si è fermato tra le mura di
casa mia ma perché non poteva fermarsi
lì io volevo volevo connettermi con le
persone e allora ho detto non può non
può fermarsi qua devo trovare il modo
sono uscita da casa col mio telefono e
ho portato con me per i miei musicisti
perché era meglio così e allora ho
deciso detto voglio fare musica per
strada voglio fare musica per strada in
diretta streaming live
voglio connettere le persone da tutte le
parti del mondo che mi stavano seguendo
e volevo renderli partecipi della mia
emozione creando un contatto non solo
con la rete ma un contatto reale fatto
di emozioni di cose che si sentono oltre
il telefono e allora ho fatto diventare
questo l'idea live street show
l'ho chiamato proprio così street show
concerto per strada uno show per strada
e ho scelto due location particolare la
città di roma e la citta di milano sono
andata nei posti più belli che mi
piacevano perché volevo trasmettere
tramite il telefonino
volevo far vedere anche le bellezze che
abbiamo noi qui in italia volevo far
vedere il colosseo castel sant'angelo a
roma ce ne sono tantissimi volevo far
vedere il duomo di milano il palazzo
sforzesco
quello era il mio background e poi
c'erano i musicisti e la mia musica ed è
stato bellissimo perché si è creata
veramente una connessione sia realizzato
il mio desiderio creare questa
interazione tra le persone è stato
pazzesco perché io cantavo live in
diretta streaming le persone mi
servivano da lì e molte persone che si
trovavano in italia venivano a trovarmi
nei live e succede ancora oggi in giro
quando sto in giro a fargli striscia
perché li faccio io li faccio come
continuamente e
questa cosa mia mi ha fatto capire
realmente che il nostro futuro è fatto
sì da internet ma dobbiamo saperlo
prendere e usarlo per essere noi stessi
per essere persone che sanno comunicare
non dobbiamo farci automatizzare quindi
vi dedico questa altra canzone io vi
ricordate prima vi ho detto che stavo
scrivendo i miei pezzi sto continuando a
scriverli ancora non posso farveli
sentire ma conto di farlo presto però
voglio farvi sentire una canzone che mi
fa volare mi fa sognare con la
creatività e mi da questo senso appunto
di crederci realmente nelle cose che
cambiano e ho rifatto totalmente
all'arrangiamento di questa canzone che
che conoscerete sicuramente e ve la dico
grazie a tutti
un sogno così non ritorni mai più
dipingevo le mani e la faccia di blu
poi d'improvviso
capito
incominciamo la cielo fini
canta
nel blu
di pinto
il blu felice
di stare là
e una volavo felice
più in alto del sole ancora più su
mentre il mondo pian piano spariva
lontano da giu
volare
canta
di pinto
felice
mister
dipinto di blu
pesce testare
adesso
no
o no
vola
no
calza
però l'effetto dei propri cede stare
nessuno
grazie a tutti ivano icardi alla
chitarra